Genetically engineered plants that can detect
bombs could replace expensive electronic detectors
within a decade.
And WASP-43b is a planet 260 light-years away
that features winds blowing at the speed of
sound in 3,000 degree temperatures which is
hot enough to melt steel.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is Mind Blow.
SpaceWorks Enterprises is designing a deep
sleep transfer habitat to help send humans
to Mars.
Funded by NASA, the project aims to utilize
Therapeutic Hypothermia to slow down astronauts’
metabolisms inducing a sleep-like inactive
state for a prolonged period of time.
Feeding would occur through intravenous nutritional
fluids delivered via catheter.
RhinoChill is an intranasal cooling system
currently used in hospitals to induce therapeutic
hypothermia keeping cardiac arrest victims
in stable condition while waiting for treatment.
But they currently only do it for up to a
week - not the 180 days it takes to get to
Mars.
So a lot more research is needed to understand
its long term mental and physical effects.
RoomAlive transforms your living room into
a video game.
It uses projector-depth camera units to create
a unified model of the room and sends that
information to a game engine.
This proof-of-concept includes a holodeck,
a whack-a-mole game using a gun controller,
a robot attack game, and booby trap virtual
darts shooting from the wall that players
try to avoid.
All of which are just samples of how the system
creates augmented entertainment experiences
that can be setup in any room.
White-footed sportive Lemurs don't like seeing
their family -- but they still care.
So to let each other know they're okay, they
all pee on the same tree at different times
throughout the night.
So yeah.
A bionic eye has allowed this man to see for
the first time in 33 years.
I first featured the Argus II Retinal Prothesis
Device on Mind Blow #59, and now Larry Hester
is the seventh person using it in the United
States.
A sensor implanted in his eye picks up light
signals sent from a camera mounted on the
glasses -- not restoring normal eyesight,
but allowing Hester to see flashes of light
that help him differentiate his surroundings,
like telling the difference between a wall
and a door.
So far, he says the best moment for him was
seeing, reaching out and touching his wife's
face.
(Can you really see?
Yes!)
This is an animated map of a humpback whale’s
song.
Michael Deal used shapes resembling the notation
of Gregorian chants to visualize whales' incredible
underwater music and hopes to further spread
awareness for saving whales.
A Swedish truck driver has been using a mind-controlled
prosthetic arm for a year with no complications.
The arm attaches to a titanium implant integrated
with the bone and it’s controlled with his
biological nerves and muscles.
And they’re currently working on sending
that communication back to the brain to provide
intuitive sensory feedback allowing people
to also feel with the prosthetic hand.
Indonesia’s capital is sinking into the
sea and they’re hoping to save it with a
$40 billion dollar project that will take
30 years.
Jakarta is dropping between 2.9 and 6.7 inches
per year mostly due to groundwater extraction
leaving large caverns under the city which
are collapsing.
So the plan is to construct 17 new islands
and a massive sea wall in Jakarta Bay to protect
from flooding - with a waterfront shaped like
the mythical Garuda bird - the national symbol
of Indonesia.
Researchers from the University of Southern
Denmark have created a crystal that can absorb
and release oxygen.
A bucket full of the material, which is a
salt made from cobalt, can suck up and store
all the oxygen in a room.
It can be reused many times without losing
its effectiveness and the hope is to someday
use it to drastically lighten oxygen tanks
-- a scuba diver would only need to carry
a few grains of the stuff because the crystal
could absorb oxygen from the water.
Finally, Susi Sie blends art and science by
using analog techniques to explore the mathematical
nature of unusual substances.
I’m gonna leave you with a ping pong playing
robot - and as always thanks for watching.